[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining this this it's it's
this week our roundtable I know man I'm
so same every day we still the majority
of the episodes we said joining us this
week yeah but that was a lot of me and
then we we had one conversation is about
changing ago we know I'm a creature of
habit but I need to be a creature that
new habit which is this week at the
roundtable of MIT
we're gonna open an envelope inside is
it is something prompted by one of you
yeah that will lead to a conversation
down a metaphorical rabbit hole and you
know what we made a literal rabbit hole
this time I don't know and you know what
there's a second envelope to that we
also don't know what's in that we might
open one we might open to just go with
us on this journey once we open the
envelope
but first I I would like to hear from
you in how you're doing stop making that
bass noise which let me make that noise
more it's like a odd it's like an odd
grunt mixed with like a subwoofer test
you know every once in a while like so
my mom has this habit where she will
just be doing something that's not
necessarily difficult something that you
would not you know categorize is
difficult like maybe she's just like
reading a magazine setting a table or
setting a plate on the table okay and
she's like it kind of like she's making
some noises and I think it's she doesn't
realize she's doing it but I've noticed
it it's just kind of making like voices
of effort even though what you're doing
doesn't require effort and so I Jesse
pointed out that I have started doing
that it's just vocalizing effort I'll
just be being a room with her
I'm just like and she's like what's
wrong I'm like oh like oh not nothing
did I do something you said you just
went now I'm like I guess it just runs
in the family
it must I so I'm curious this about me
well I thought you were doing it to
distract me from the question was you
know don't answer I'm happy I'm curious
because you've been 10 days being the
mom and the dad in the house
I'm glad you rounded it up to 10
although it was just 8 I'm glad did
youdid die if it seemed like a double
digit I didn't know if I if I if that
didn't include travel days yep
so he didn't included travel days my
wife she went on an excursion went to
she went to find herself and there was a
question if she was gonna come back
right the details that you have
associated with the trip are interesting
to me and they're they're all incorrect
okay she had a friend who was going to
Africa for work and a good friend of
hers and she was like oh I'll go I'll go
with you mmm so she went to South Africa
had a great time she went to Cape Town
yeah
and there's no water there that that's
just a side curiosity but the main
curiosity running out of water yeah I
have is um how did I do
she did come back right about yeah what
do you mean she made it back she decided
to come back
she was always planning to come back but
because I mean you know South Africa I
don't really know what city is she was
in Cape Town I don't know what cities
more dangerous than other but it has a
reputation for being a place that you
just don't wanna you got to watch you
back you know she actually told me a
story of she just went out by herself
one day and she was in like a relatively
like you know quote-unquote
safe part of the city but a place that
wasn't necessarily known for like
violent crime because there's a lot of
violent crime and robbery and armed
robbery there but that's not what I
meant by she might not come back no no
but seriously ladies did she actually
she and she was kind of being dramatic
but she talked quite a bit about if I
don't come back like we actually had a
conversation about her funeral
ooh like she talked about details of her
funeral which was interesting and I was
like they're not gonna die don't just
let's not talk about that just come back
but while she was there she goes out one
day by herself to the shopping area and
that's what it was called she went to
shopping area a shopping area okay like
a you know one of the roads that was
streets that's like known for its
shopping okay and there was a woman like
a woman who kind of kind of come up came
up to her kind of aggressively asking
for money and was kind of following her
but she kept following her like it was
one of those things where you kind of
say no I'm sorry I can't help but they
continued to follow and then she's
getting a little bit freaked out and
then they have these public safety
officers so I don't know exactly what
this is but it seems like there are
these people who are not exactly cops
not exactly you know civilians who are
stationed to all these places throughout
the city that are kind of just in there
to make sure that everything is okay
they packing and I I didn't ask her that
question because I was thinking that do
they have guns but I don't know all I
know is that a public safety officer
kind of came up and told this woman who
was like aggressively coming after Jesse
oh wow to like back off and then she
walks a little bit further another
Public Safety Officer comes up to her
and she had on a backpack Jesse had on a
backpack and had on a very very small
necklace like a necklace you could
barely even see and the public safety
officer was like you need to turn your
backpack around so that the pack is in
the front and you need to take your
chain and put it in your bag because
somebody will come up and rip the chain
off your neck whoa and then she was like
okay I'm not going out by myself again
so there was some there was some calls
for concern even though I think I just
kind of minimized it but she made it
back yeah it's not good for your back to
help carry a backpack around like that
what's it go on the front really what
you should do it's not the takeaway
you're going to do that
you should wear a backpack on the front
but you should wear a dummy backpack on
the back to balance it out yeah if
people can take the dummy backpacks just
full of books like from another dollar
store breakaway necklaces perhaps yeah
exactly
oh I thought you're gonna say you wear
the backpack forward and then you wear
another shirt over it so it looks like
you got your like lumpy pregnant okay
you know how some of your less of a
target that way well that's true maybe
maybe you're more of a target I don't
know anyway thanks for asking about me
that is what you were asking how I was
doing so I'll get back to talking about
me let's talk about me how about that
she she had she had a harrowing
experience on the streets of Cape Town
let's talk about youth I you had to
raise your kids without her for eight
days now that's danger you know it was
pretty smooth I am I'm pretty pretty
hands-off and by that I mean things like
well first of all the kids have quite a
few activities that they are involved in
things that they do during the week some
weeknights and there was some sporting
events on the weekend and you know I I
took care of all that everybody got to
where they needed to be on time and etc
but uber yeah I just put him in a lift
okay
no I carried them I drove them and
incidentally did you know that our
friend Michael who has the little the
little dog yeah he sent the dog to
Williams house in a lift did you know
this no that's how he got the dog to
William are you serious he put the dog
in a crate in the lift and sent it
across town when the lift shows up
you're explaining to the lift hey I'm
not going I just want you to take this
crate with a dog in it to this house and
the driver was didn't speak good English
and like so he couldn't really there was
no real confirmation that everything was
going to be okay but it was just like I
mean I have a dog I put the dog in the
car and I've typed in the address just
take this dog to that address it ended
up working the dogs fine the dog made it
I
do that with my child though I probably
do that with Barbara that's crazy
singing anyway why didn't he just ride
because he didn't want to ride across
town and then right back I think they
were in a hurry to get out of town and
it was like the last-minute thing was
all my dog over anyway
I my hands off I mean things like there
is an uber for kids though by the way
there's an app is there not where you
can put your kid in a in a car and it's
sort of it's a certified ride service
it's got like a bounce house in it or
something no it's just a certified pit
ride service for kids for your children
but the drivers are like they passed
like a second level of test to be like I
thought this thing children yeah I might
just be thinking it needs to exist
well I we have sent I have sent Locke
about two years ago when he was like 12
he and his friend who was a year older
than him we sent them about five miles
in an uber one time and some people
right now are thinking it that is a
horrible parenting decision but once you
ride in a couple of words I don't think
there's nothing I mean we like we vetted
the guy you know like when he showed up
he looked at his stars
we're not he wasn't just highly rated
but like we had a conversation with him
you know and we talked about there's any
if we feel anything weird at all about
this driver we're not gonna do this we
didn't feel anything weird I'm pretty
surprised you did it really yeah I don't
know I did I love your own in an uber
I'm not I'm a pretty like I was
suggesting I'm pretty yeah yeah jesse
was like a surprises integral to the
decision yes Wow I mean especially cuz
it wasn't that far it's not like I mean
you couldn't just take you kid I don't
remember the circumstances but I
remember thinking was a great idea so
when I was taking care of my kids
so Shepherd is really in he's got a
switch she's got a Nintendo switch and
he spends quite a bit of time on that
now he has is that how you talked to him
he is no way to talk to him through this
which unfortunately no I I limit him
well I have parental control set up on
the switch and
of the things you can do with the
parental controls app is you can set a
limit yeah
so I set one hour if he decides to do it
on a day he gets one hour of time yeah
and I I have that have like apps running
on the kids screens like there's a
shared family laptop and and like the
kids that have phones and you monitor
all that in terms of like time and stuff
like that so that do the homework and
they're not just on screens but here's
the problem with it it just gets to an
hour and it sends him a warning and it
says you have reached your limit for the
day or whatever so for shephard
translation is it doesn't shut off after
that you don't care what it keeps you
can keep playing so the translation is
good job shepherd achievement unlocked
right so I look at the app and it says
your child went two hours and 40 minutes
over his one hour limit today I'm like
well what the crap is the limit for he
was gonna give Shepherd a warning and
that's it no he's gotta be you know but
I did tell him I was like Shepherd by
the end of it he did this good for a few
days in a row and eventually I said
Shepherd if you go over the limit if I
get the alert that you went over the
limit then you can't play the next day
so did he stick with it after that well
we kind of came up with that plan like
the day before she came back oh it took
me a while to realize what was happening
you you get you you you discuss the plan
but then you put him and his switch into
an uber and then they you know he looked
up from the switch he was in Tijuana I
should have done that but interestingly
I told him I said Shepherd you've got to
get off screens you've got to do
something other than be on screens you
got to stop playing Zelda that's his
game with his life he's playing Zelda
and so I'm like I tell him that and then
35 30 minutes later I come into the
kitchen and we have like a we have an
iMac that's kind of off to the side of
the kitchen and he's watching YouTube
videos about Zelda but how to play Zelda
any and I bet you he says what my kids
say which is well I'm not I'm not
playing so it doesn't count I was like
well it's still a screen but the thing
is Lincoln will
I'll tell Lincoln well you know I don't
want you to be on screen so much son I
don't want you to play whatever game
you're playing I know the games but I
just not worth mentioning at this point
and he's like well I don't want you be
on screens he's like well I'm not I'm
like what are you doing right now he's
like well I'm on Amazon I'm just kind of
looking at some stuff but that's a
screen he's that but I'm not playing
again I'm shopping dad I'm just I'm just
I'm just I'm putting together my
wishlist right right that's what Shepard
does and that's different different well
but I will say it is different there in
his experience there is a distinct
difference and I think that studies show
this you know that's a that's a studies
have shown this at least my kids have
told me shut it studies have shown this
playing games is is a significantly
different experience on your brain than
just watching television or movies so
like sitting down and binge watching
something your brain goes into a very
like you're not making any judgments
you're not built you're not connecting
any dots you're basically just kind of
taking in this story versus a game that
involves strategy so I kind of go back
to that sometimes when I look at how
long he's been in this game but I think
I spent a lot of time playing the
original Zelda like I would say I'm up
there and the extra room we called it I
never did it I mean my name's bunch of
time in the game I never I never once
played the game yeah all you had to do
was get into no power and you didn't
have to play you just it just didn't
seem we hadn't an hour
they have YouTube to tell them exactly
how to how to beat the specific problem
I you know I'll say quickly I wanted to
spend some time with Lincoln I was like
all right we're gonna do something today
you're not gonna stay here and stay on
screens just because it's Saturday
morning so I took him in a friend of his
to a place where we played VR video
games we're not gonna stay here inside
and to play video games and watch TV
we're gonna go to a facility where we
have to pay to be on a screen okay son
yeah we did that and it was actually and
I took Lily too so it was the four of us
all with like the VR headsets on super
cool playing in the same world and it
was it was it was a zombie shooter game
where it's like you're you're in the
desert of Arizona it's called a Arizona
something Arizona desert and um Arizona
some you can only move under this tent
but then there's like zombies coming
from every whichaway and let me tell you
there was fun after it took 20 minutes
for us to figure out how to actually
start playing the game I had a visceral
fear response I'm a number of times to
the zombies yeah I actually felt like
what I'm doing right now is traumatic
like shooting zombies like it was it was
scary because they would crawl up they
were your kids scared they would crawl
no that's what's disturbing is that they
weren't scared but I was scared they
would crawl up to your feet when you
weren't looking if you're looking one
way and you'd literally turn around and
look down and there'd be a zombie
clawing at your ankles like I would jump
and then the three of them would see me
jumping and cowering and there's dad
he's gonna be a great leader in the
apocalypse I picked up you could pick up
a tennis ball and throw it at him you
were the tennis ball boy wouldn't do
anything yeah I'm interested in doing
area intense
speaking of intense I have every
intention for every reason to believe
that going down this rabbit hole is
going to be incredibly intense is that a
good Segway oh that was good and now
you're gonna say but first but first we
are gonna let you know where you can get
these amazing shirts that were wearing
now be your mythical best baseball tee
with the quarter length sleeves hey
going that's nice man it's got the like
retro faded pattern there with a little
like dot matrix action and then I've got
another mythical shirt it's a taco shell
with a hamburger cheeseburger inside the
taco shell and then it says mythical
right down here as if somebody with the
last name of mythical was like the
artiste
and so it's like cheeseburger will it
taco but it's also just a cheeseburger
in a taco shell which you ain't got to
know nothing no that's cool both of
these and many more we are putting out a
lot of new designs experimenting with a
lot of different things seeing what you
guys like and also try to do some things
like this shirt that I've got on which
isn't necessarily like hey I wear this
shirt and because I I was the kind of
guy growing up that I wasn't always into
wearing the things that like identified
me with something like he said that like
I'm a fan of this thing but if it was
more like that's just a cheeseburger
inside a taco shell that's cool bring it
on I would be all over this
and I am all over it and that's why I'm
wearing it right now you need to get all
over it Medical dot store it's all over
you my friend
yeah I'm grabbing the top envelope I
only want to pretend as if there is one
envelope I think that there's another
one but I don't want you to don't want
it to be in the back of our heads that
we're gonna go to the second envelope
well unless the rabbit-hole reaches a
dead end well not a dead end the
conclusion all right I just don't I
don't want it to seem like a defeat if
we open the second thing I don't want to
seem like oh we got we got to prove to
ourselves we can talk one thing into the
ground through the ground here it is the
one envelope mark M I'm not gonna say
his last name because I don't know what
he's about to say or ask and it may be
incriminating if you guys were stuck on
an island and could only bring three
items apiece and one mythical crewmember
oh gosh
who and what would you bring and how
long do you think you'd last now this
has got to be a team of I mean this is
like a frickin riddle here what three
things do you bring is this is not a
okay and this is mark Martinez mark okay
all right we're up to the challenge we
can figure this out the mythical crew
member thing is is kind of tough just
create a little dicey you know what's
wrong answer that - now are we saying
that stuck on an island are we saying
that this is this is one mythical crew
member between the two of us are we each
get one well we could bring three items
apiece and one
remember between the 200 so we can bring
six things right you know I think well
yeah I mean you got it you gotta have
some I'm assuming this island you know
it's just like it's it's just is I don't
know what the terrain is I don't know if
it's jungle I don't know if it's desert
I don't know if it's populated now that
wouldn't make a but the implication is
ain't nobody there let's just assume
that it is your typical if we are stuck
on Kauai like South I wouldn't I
wouldn't probably I'd probably bring
like some toothpaste I think the
implication is this is an island where
there are no people other than you he
didn't say deserted but let's just
assume stuck on an island I mean by your
definition we are currently stuck on an
island you know I'm saying I were every
continent is ultimately an island right
so no that's right so this is like
there's nobody there except the person
that we're going to bring in the items
that we're bringing with us right well I
at first I'm thinking something really
sharp an axe but then you got to have an
axe you gotta have you got to have like
um you gotta have a sharp piece of metal
and it might as well be an axe if you're
going that far I again I know as much as
I would like but not much I'm not gonna
deny him blacksmith work I am NOT an AI
am NOT an expert I only like to pretend
that I am in survival er I like the idea
of being ready for the apocalypse but
I'm actually not ready for it you know
what I mean but I don't know if a knife
or an ax is a better choice but I have
to assume that you can do most things
with a with an axe that you can do with
a knife there's a lot of things you
can't do with a knife that you can do
with an axe you think that was logical
and we have to think about this together
like if I bring an axe you don't have to
bring an axe or should I bring an axe
and you bring a knife and then we got
all bases covered because you you want
to like cut open like the pigs that
we're gonna kill right you know and like
but I gotta go to the island has pigs
well every island has got pigs when was
the last time somebody crash-landed on
an island and there wasn't like a a
weird Boer situation yeah well some sort
of animal that we can get our teeth
around
I recently re-watched castaway with my
family because we were going on this
family movie Tom Hanks bender somehow we
ended up watching Sully
and then the next weekend I think we
watched - a few key scenes we watched
Forrest Gump as a family can you
describe the scenes that you skipped and
know and then we watched something we
watched a league of their own which has
Tom Hanks how much time and then not
only one night was a span how many
things like this is like a bunch of
Saturdays in a row specifically like
we're gonna really we're gonna go deep
into the Tom Hanks universe well I what
you'll find if you start to think about
it just look at my list though it's all
great families alright great stuff and
then we watch castaway riches that was a
good one and the kids start saying
things like oh now now there's so many
memes that makes sense now we talked
about this that's what Locke said after
for Scot man yeah and Lily said the same
thing because she speaks in meme now
right that's all that that's the only
way they can communicate but anyway and
I know that you've been rewatching lost
with your family so based on these two
entertainment experiences alone we
should have better answers if we're now
what we've we've set an axe and a knife
so now we have we have for things to go
I guess a volleyball now it's how fun
Tom Hanks and in ship because he started
he cuz you know you talk about the whole
starting a fire situation do you
honestly think we could start fire yeah
losing friction you won't know we could
start it with the butane lighter that
would be the third item that we bring
any any I mean can you get does the
route there's like a huge freakin
butane refill count as part of the item
I think what we got to do is we got to
get a now first of all I do think that
while we do have a fire with the butane
lighter we also need to be learning how
to start a friction fire but I think you
got to approach this in two different
ways
right one side of the problem is we have
a fire that never stops
you know like you've heard you've heard
about all like a pilot light well I seem
to remember that in some cultures that
I've read about in the past that it was
like someone's job to always have the
fire going like you always have a fire
going it's not that hard to start a fire
is it like you don't want it oh my gosh
this thing has to be an eternal flame
well no you want the fire burning at
night as a signal because we don't want
to be there forever and you want it
burning during the day so you just don't
want it to get too cold but then but
then we're teaching each other not
teaching each other but we're we're
trying out to trying based on everything
we've seen in movies to learn how to do
the friction fire so eventually the
butane lighter is just a just a backup
for rainy days could we have an internet
connection that like is the new version
hot spot is the fourth item like we had
access to the internet but we didn't
have any but somehow this is almost like
a black mirror meets lost situation
where you
we couldn't gain rescue via the internet
but we can access it and just like any
normal person I think that would be I
think that's what I'm highly frustrating
no because you got to bring a Wi-Fi
that's first of all is it realistic as
this is this situation is right that's
all that you're really I think you're
breaking I think you're breaking the
question apart
because we can't we can't have the
internet we can't have a functioning
internet because now you're talking but
we got electricity I was just trying to
hack Elena system but yeah so we got two
knives and we've got I think maybe we we
don't have something to start a fire
maybe we just maybe but if we don't get
a fire that animal in a homunculus we
could die first week probably water
filter water felt like a Mike
something micron whatever the number is
that you need remember that time that we
went on a camping trip with roommate
Tim I brought a water filter and Tim is
the is the college roommate of ours that
he's the reason why the rat lived in the
couch he's the one that we say that he
was always messy we just give him such a
hard time and we believe that he
deserves it he's the guy who he was a
chem major and we went hiking we went to
Linville Gorge one time and he insisted
he insisted on wearing his steel toed
boots
and then he got so much chafing and
blisters from these boots that he
literally started hiking in socks yeah
you remember that yeah well I did not
and that because I think at the point
where the it wasn't like it the heel or
anything was at the point where the
steel toe stopped and it became regular
leather something about that juncture in
the shoe oceans
got very painful for him and he just
kept getting further further behind we
would stop and wait for him and then all
of a sudden we realize he's holding his
boots he's hiking in socks yeah and then
we're like mumbling to herself it's like
don't say anything to him just he's
upset you don't want to have somebody
that's that down on it it's like having
somebody with like a broken hip hiking
with you so you're saying that Tim we're
not bringing Tim he's not a mythical
crew member no I haven't even gotten to
what I remembered which was he's a chem
major and like he said another time that
we went camping he what we get to our
first campsite and all of a sudden he
breaks out all this tubing you remember
this yeah yeah he breaks out all this to
me we're like Tim what we have plenty of
water
what is this tubing what are you making
here the car is right there I'm making a
water filter iine it was it had charcoal
in it yeah it was a whole filtration
system that he like built from scratch
and he got the water from the creek and
we drank it I
don't recall personally drain his water
I drank it I trusted him you trusted him
he made a mistake
Kim major he was not a chemist he was
studying it he wasn't he had a water
filter doesn't it's not that advanced
it's not that he has a lot to say about
advance of a technology yeah but he was
also hiking in socks I mean at some
point I'd forgot about that but but I'm
thinking about the initial like because
obviously we're talking like a life
straw we need to figure out a way to
have like a sustainable water source we
need to find fresh water we need to use
the fire that we're gonna learn how to
start with just friction to like
sanitize the water but there's a there's
a learning curve to all that you know so
we got to have we got to have to me it's
less about thinking about all the things
that are gonna work long-term because
people might be like guys why are you
using butane lighters and water filters
is because we got to make it six to
eight weeks just to get our bearings to
just to develop a civilization I'll tell
you something else you need and I think
I learned this from the time I used to
spend with Bear Grylls on television on
television you got to keep spirits up
you've got you've got to actually
believe you're gonna make it that that
does this translate into who we would
bring with us I don't know yet I I'm not
I'm putting out there that this is the
most overlooked and possibly the most
important thing is just a positive
outlook a confident assertion of
survival that very quickly I think means
we need some form of entertainment mmm
you got to have something besides
tic-tac-toe and a stand in the sand
would you tow like a bocce ball set like
a bocce boss because you if here's that
here's the analogy I was telling
somebody this yesterday you know we were
hanging out with with friends and our
kids were there our youngest kids
landownership were there and we sent
them outside so that we could have adult
time and like have adult conversation
without them coming in and again and
then this is before you broke let
Shepherd get on
isn't into no switch you did a good job
for a couple hours yeah without letting
him have it
him and Lando were out there fighting
over the dog that took the uber by the
way right and then after they got tired
of the dog they were given a little
trampoline and then that they were then
they started fighting over who was gonna
be on the trampoline because it wasn't
enough room for both him at the same
time and then all of a sudden Lando
comes in with a piece of the trampoline
that they had sprung off of it so they
sprouted a big hole in the trampoline
because once I went Boing and when we
were leaving later it turns out that we
were trying to put the trampoline back
together because you want to leave
everything better than you found it we
couldn't find this other piece and I was
like you know what it's really dark I'm
sure in daylight I was talking to Jaden
I was like I'm sure you'll find it in
other words I'm not gonna stay here the
dark help you look for is small you can
let her saw it it was like a little
plastic bracket they don't know it was a
trampoline like a exercise trampoline
yeah yes yeah but it was fancier than
that and it had like little plastic
brackets but I said basically I said I'm
leaving I'm not helping you look for
this isn't dark but I'm sure you'll find
it tomorrow and the like but I said you
know what the key is the key is
believing that you will find it lots of
times when you're looking for something
even if you got like a huge search party
and I'm not trying to be depressing
let's not talk about a missing child
let's just talk about like like a needle
in a haystack
almost literally and if you got all your
friends coming or I got to find this
needle in this haystack there's usually
one person in the back of their mind
it's like I'm picturing the moment when
I do find this needle I hold it up and
I'm like I'm not gonna be triumphant I'm
just gonna be like hey guys check out
what I found everybody comes over and
they all look I can't believe it he's
holding the needle that was hidden in
the haystack and he's thinking in his
mind whenever I comes over I'm just
gonna be like nonchalant and then
everybody's gonna be like in projecting
yourself in that situation as the hero
that found the needle all you need is
one person in a group
who believes that they can manifest that
situation but in ours you know what what
did we will find the hero I mean you'll
find a needle what do we believe in in
the hero if you're not him are we
believing that we'll be rescued we're
believing that we will survive but how
does any do it I few confused by my
speech he's not gonna work when we're
out an island I've given it to you again
because I'll be like remember on the
podcast when I talked about the needle
in the haystack all we have to do is
believe that we will survive I think we
analogy with the needle is that we will
not die but I agree in bringing a can-do
attitude but that doesn't count as when
we write we need an item that at our
lowest point gives us a can-do attitude
but bocce-ball says not a bad idea but
it's kind of stupid we let's get you
smarter we can create a bocce ball so
out of out of the correct size rocks we
can do that right not really I think
that we've got I think one of the one of
the six items needs to be something that
it it's a hope Giver
it needs to be like again for Tom Hanks
it was the volleyball it was Wilson well
I think with the knife we could carve
things and you've got art you know I'm
saying I'm trying to think of ways to
double down on some of the items mm-hmm
we could do tree art we could become
experts in like carving weird things
into trees and that would be our
entertainment we could actually create
little we could do I don't know who our
third person is gonna be we got to
answer that question in a second but we
the three of us we let do voices we have
a whole forest what we could do is have
like a forest of characters we did you
carve the different characters and then
we void that we create our own create
our own entertainment system that's just
us voicing different trees and
entertainment
we call it the entertainment system and
it's just a section of the forest it's
see I've answered you in a sculpture if
I can create a whole play that is about
you you can do it you're gonna be you
can find the needle it could be about
finding a needle in a haystack it could
be
being rescued it could be about starting
a sustainable civilization right that's
all in our imagination and with the axe
and the knife I mean the more I think
about it we might need like a second axe
to say we could call it knife flicks
knife flicks yeah it's like we're
watching this stuff we've made with our
knives yep
we had knife flicks and chill so we
won't know see what we got to talk about
that third person let's come back to the
other two items because I think this is
a this we're gonna get into some this
could get a little weird here a second
oh is that right yeah right because you
have to ask your core self the question
is the point of the third person just
for us to sir just for us to survive or
is this do we need to populate a hobby
lately why I mean just I'm just saying
that is a legitimate question
if we can just agreed right now that
this is not about populating the island
no red that's make it about populating
the isle let's choose and let's choose
an employee let's freakin what I judge
it's wrong with I'm just throwing
everything out there just we didn't make
the best choice this is nut first of all
okay we would never talk about this just
if we weren't being recorded but I want
to remind you that we are it's being
distributed hold on this is one of the
episodes going on the internet this
isn't for the private collection even
you just think even you're just bringing
that up but for comedic effect problem
at I thought that one out of four
episodes was for the private collection
sorry I forget this okay so we're not
gonna populate the island I'm just I'm a
40 years old and you're your old fart
hold on we both have vasectomies I mean
what are we even thinking we'd have to
get wait that's your reason we're moving
on we'd have to bring a doctor who's the
third person who can reverse our
vasectomies he has to have the tools
that he needs to reverse the reverse
ectomy why's it gotta be a heat well
it's got to be ashy because then we have
to impregnate not oh we have to exactly
right we need a female doctor right
they're worse for us what the medic I'm
sorry listen I'm just trying to be
practical gosh you're the one who made
it awkward it's not Mars we're not we're
not starting to civilization we're just
we're just coasting the rest of our
lives this is a theme we're bringing
along somebody who's gonna help us
survive
okay then boost morale okay all right
you know what
any mythical employee would be a great
addition to our squad but we have to we
have to pick one and I think we got to
go with somebody who not only boosts
morale but is like more capable than
than we are I mean I think we're in like
Morgan territory honestly you know what
I'm saying I think I think yeah he's
mean he's not gonna die anytime soon
he can solve a lot of different problems
he's quiet he's not annoying in last
thing we need is another talker yeah
he's he's not annoying he's just a guy
that while we're sitting around carving
the treat the entertainments just
thinking he's he's coming up with things
you know what I'm saying
I think Morgan think Morgan is you know
no he can't I get pregnant he jet I know
that he gently redirects me constantly
you know especially when it comes to
safety like he's got a way about himself
that doesn't complain cuz I mean you
guys you guys know that I can't have I'm
not allowed to use a knife on good
mythical morning but Morgan is always
you think that chase would be the one
who was like constantly nervous and he's
only nervous when I have darts like
Morgan before before we start rolling on
an episode he'll like come up if there's
anything that I could really hurt myself
within like he always has a way to just
kind of gently bring me bring me to a
realization of what's best for you
what's best for me yeah
and I'm glad he's there so I don't have
to Morgan is mortgages a father
in a more direct way
he can be here both of our dad could be
a dad sometimes what is Morgan that's
what Morgan is Jamie
what is Morgan to you he's the guy that
says things to you so I don't have to
yeah right he's a mediator now okay so
we know what would what would be great
about Morgan he's got a can-do attitude
and he does he can't he has a can-do
attitude and then he does now Jordan you
know manure mythical crew member yeah
he's it's fresher he could be cotton
candy Randy some days and cotton candy
Rainey is you know we've already
established as one guys in one yeah and
he also can be sexy fireman you know he
did that one time right and I'm sure you
can probably invent new new characters
too you know I don't know how capable he
is he's like from Orange County you know
it probably is not you know good with an
axe yeah he's good with flip-flops
I bet yep right but he's definitely for
in terms of your the morale-boosting I
mean I think we can handle that
you don't think we need cotton candy
Randy no he doesn't like me he did yeah
he likes me thanks many more it was kind
of a selfish choice well but on your
part that could be something else so
Morgan's coming he's got a crate full of
good stuff because he can bring whatever
he want really no he can't bring what he
wants
so right now we've got a knife and an
axe you may think that's excessive in
the whole metal tool to category do we
need like a fishing rod or in a net net
a net if we got a knife in an axe a
butane lighter a water filter in a net
what is that oh we're down to that's
five I mean only if you're on board with
this with a net and that's a good idea
because a fish and we can catch people
as well when you catch all kinds of
things with a net Morgan gets there's
people swimming by the island if there's
like I don't know if there's the others
you know speaking of lost but let's just
assume there are other people but you
can also
using net as like a structure system for
the tarp that we'll need to put over top
of or forget the tarp because they only
have one more thing we're just gonna put
Brent fronds we're gonna put fronds over
the net and that's going to be our idea
for making shelter at first until we
realize that we can't fish with the net
when it's our Hut and I've got what I
think is the best possible item for the
six item can I guess what it is by
asking yes or no questions I think I
just need to tell you
is it a prot is it a packaged product
it's a yacht oh it's a yacht that kind
of spoiled my game and ship there see
with this type of attitude I'm aroused
gonna sink real quick I instigate a game
and you're like a boiler alert it's a
yacht it's a yacht I mean I could have
said that first yacht yacht a gas
guzzler how much gas you only have it
it's a yacht full of gas ooh that's a
quandary right there it's awful so we
got that we never want to use no it's a
yacht we leave the island with we don't
even have to have this this this mental
exercise because we just take our yacht
and go and go back to civilization do we
have enough gas to get there yeah yeah
so I mean I think we just solved it I
think we did it's kind of an easy
question Morgan's there he can probably
drive a boat drive a boat what we're
gonna give him special training we're
gonna get him on lynda.com yacht
training series video series you wanna
you want to go to the second envelope hi
could you do like when you brought up
the yacht you're like I'm done with this
question mark thanks for that thanks for
helping us think through it they're
survivalists out there who have gouged
their eyes out listening to that
conversation well yeah if you are if you
know anything about surviving let us
know how good our first five choices
were yeah that's what I want to know
because I have no idea this is from
Maira what is it about certain foods
that makes them only fitting for certain
times of day is there some bodily
circadian rhythm related function
happening that makes us only want pizza
for dinner and not breakfast this is a
great question I have thought about it
well first of all I've had you have
thought about it I have asked myself the
question before why is it that we limit
ourselves to these these these items for
breakfast
well maybe this isn't the right way to
do it but instinct of it I just want to
point out the outliers that like I've
eaten cold pizza for a late breakfast so
brunch maybe doesn't count but like a
bona fide I'm getting up at my normal
time in my normal routine and I'm gonna
I mean either slice a pizza for like hot
pizza like order fresh out of the bag
type of thing that does sound weird but
whenever a family whenever we're like as
a family were like alright what do you
guys want to do before you watch another
Tom Hanks movie what do you want to eat
for dinner and if anyone says immediate
eruption is celebration it's like it's
like a gleeful subversion of all
societal expectations rolled up into the
perfect meal and it's a beautiful thing
to subvert dinner with breakfast but
subverting breakfast with dinner is just
nasty right so I think there may be a
clue in this well I think maybe we can
zero in a little bit what is it about
eggs let's just talk eggs okay how did
eggs become associated with being eaten
in the morning the rooster the rooster
crows right is so is it in the hen lays
is it the fact that isn't it true that
chickens let hens lay eggs every day
like that they let they lay an egg every
day I believe I believe so roughly which
is just a fascinating thing do they as
often as you take a Dookie yeah but
think yeah
chicken dukey's out an egg freaking egg
that has a shell and a lot of Dookie too
by the way
yeah but in addition to the Dookie they
have these little eggs at manufacturing
centers for eggs now you can leave is it
because you you go out in the morning
you go to the chicken coop and you've
got that you've got food for that day
like yeah you might as well just eat it
now and so we just begin to associate it
as a culture with eating it morning cuz
imma throw it into before refrigeration
so we're talking the cultural norm of
eggs but you can leave an egg out all
day easy you can I mean you can leave it
even out weeks yes
store them up you can leave it a hen can
lay only one egg in a day and we'll have
some days when it does not lay an egg at
all right so it's not it's not it's not
like clockwork every single day but
Handley it is possible I got into Jacobs
laptop I was in this I saw I I'm that's
what I thought I think it has something
I think maybe better brought Jacob with
his laptop to the island I'm sorry
you're sitting here the whole time and
we didn't even consider taking it's one
item in one hand I had to have hurt can
you drive it can you drive a boat yeah
you agree with Morgan okay okay
well you're glad we're not dragging you
to the island because by the way we
freaking drugged Morgan to the island he
could the whole time Morgan's like guys
I could have been back living my life
but you chose me to exile in this island
he liked it you want to go back to the
other question I'm sorry Jacob cuz I
want you to come to the island because I
think that we're thinking something here
I do too so in the in the question is
our eggs if we're right now first of all
its cultural norms that's what I'm here
for surely people eat different things
in different places when I when I was in
Eastern Europe I remember that they ate
a lot of like salami x' like the
breakfast would often be like what we
would call a charcuterie plate you know
I'm saying so like assorted cheeses and
meats and isn't that we don't eat meat
and cheese for breakfast we do but like
the way that it was presented was very
much like this is new this isn't the way
that we think about breakfast
but when but in other cultures there
also serve that as dessert instead of
desert like a charcuterie plate yeah
cheese can be part of the search but
which is weird to me too
but is it the case that everywhere on
earth eggs are a part of the the
breakfast meal because then it would it
would hold what we just talked about if
it's true that the reason that eggs are
associated with breakfast is because
people go outside and the eggs are there
and they're fresh and they just came out
of the the hen and then you go and you
eat them then that should be true
throughout the world why wouldn't that
apply it just as much to dinner though
it's like the the last meal you know
because you go out there and see if it
laid an egg it laid an egg when I went
to granny Capps his house which is my ex
stepdads mom every other Sunday when he
was still married to my mom we go to his
mama's house for Sunday fried chicken
well first of all occasionally the fried
chicken would be one of her chickens
that she had of course locked the head
off of him fried but most of the time
store-bought store-bought chicken but I
would go out into her chicken coop after
lunch every other Sunday and get the
eggs for her that's an experience I had
and I'm what I'm saying is it was after
lunch it was after lunch she didn't go
but you could but you could have gone in
the morning while I won there well okay
listen maybe she left him for me as a
treat for me to find let's approach this
from a different way so here in the US
there's a few things that are that we
consider normal right if you guess salad
you have the salad before your meal and
then you have your main course and you
have a dessert now dessert as we've
we've actually talked about on the show
before on GMM scientifically one of the
reasons that you always feel like you
have a little bit of
room for dessert is your stomach
actually responds differently to sugars
and fats so you sometimes you're eating
a meal that's got a lot of fats and a
lot of animal protein cheese that kind
of thing and you kind of get to a place
where like I can't eat another bite of
this burger I can't eat another bite of
this cheesy fatty thing that I'm eating
is my main course and then somebody
breaks out the chocolate pie and you're
like oh I got room for that I'm old and
I'm gonna open up my dessert stomach and
you literally scientifically do have a
dessert stomach not it's not a second
stomach but when sugar hits your stomach
it actually causes it to expand a little
bit so it actually makes sense that you
follow up fats with sugars now salads we
start with salads but that is not a
cultural that's a cultural norm here but
that's not a cultural norm elsewhere
I remember my sister-in-law who married
you know Mary Chris whom his his dad is
Palestinian his mom is Lebanese and like
the kind of aid works introduced to a
totally different cuisine like mm-hmm
Ashley was through this and they were
going to these meals and they were all
eating like a salad after their meal
really yeah and I don't know if that was
just something that was again I don't
know if that was something that was
isolated to them but the sugar thing
makes sense but I think that our choices
for what we when we eat things I think a
lot of it may just be completely
determined by all these different
factors and if you just like raise the
kid up and said eggs are going to be
associated with the evening and then
really hearty meals are gonna be
associated with the very beginning of
the day I don't I'm just doing other do
you think that would backfire do you
think that trying to give somebody a
really hearty fatty meaty meal at the
beginning of the day is like they're
just body's not ready for it so you got
to go something a little bit lighter
like cereal cuz would you well it could
be debilitating you know I think you
know you start to feel like you can
afford to indulge in something that's
like a gravy based me
at the end of your day when afterward
you're just gonna pull the lever on your
recliner as opposed to you're gonna pull
the knob on your door and encounter life
yeah you know work out a good whatever
do your job
it can't be something that requires too
much from your body yeah I remember the
hardest I ever worked physically was I
wrote about this in the book of
mythicality like farming and Barney
tobacco that once summer from my Nana's
brothers yeah
and my Aunt Frances made them she made
the meanest biscuits man and all this
stuff and so we go back to her house for
lunch every day and she they would have
the heaviest lunch I'm talking like fry
burgers and biscuits and gravy and all
types of stuff like that just heavy
stuff and after a after a week or two of
that I I just couldn't I could I learned
that I couldn't handle it like I would
eat it and then I would fall asleep
because he would watch uncle uncle Ross
would watch the weed eat and then he'd
watch the news in the weather you know a
farmer of the day news yep farmer always
watching the news always watching the
weather and I would like conk out on the
floor and then it would it would they
have to scrape me up like scraping gum
off of off the pavement it was horrible
so you learn your lesson so then you
know breakfast is the most important
meal of the day is what they say right
you got a but just having a little
sugary cereal thing is not gonna cut it
I try not to let my kids have that so I
think but why is one works there's a
there's a middle ground right why if you
put this is a fascinating question
because why if I put pork sausage on a
biscuit I call that breakfast but if I
put beef patty on a piece of bread
that's lunch and Carl's jr. will they
try to slip in their burgers in a
breakfast on their biscuits or slip in
the burgers yes if you go to cross jr.
Hardee's that they'll have all the
typical breakfast stuff and then you
could add a burger patty that any
and some of it they have pictures in
them on the breakfast menu like they are
really throwing everything at it but
that's crazy when you when you isolate
it down to something as simple as
whether or not it's ground pork with
Rice's versus ground beef without spices
why is there a point around 10:30 11:00
a.m. where all of a sudden you can make
this transition it doesn't make any
sense I think that there are something
and I'm real contributing scientific
cultural things that like contributed to
it but at this point it's arbitrary
there's no difference between the way
pork tastes at 10:30 or the way it
tastes at 11 o'clock
when do they start stop serving
breakfast at McDonald's well they serve
it all day now right they serve it all
day because traditionally when did they
stop cuz now in a crete people got
really excited about it and again I
think breakfast came I think it's 11 but
- maybe 10:30 but breakfast can you push
on it you can go and abrade breakfast
and go anywhere bringing it bringing
that like like eating lasagna for
breakfast yeah that sounds good they
don't even do that in Italy do they I
don't think they eat lasagna in Italy I
think we did that - well that's a shame
probably in a completely American yeah
probably it's chicken lo mein for
breakfast dumplings like when we went to
New York Stevie was all excited about
taking us to that um the dumpling
dumpling place for breakfast right and I
loved it because I had a hard time I can
that says I'm a justice so it's just an
association your body knows somehow I
can't excite could explain it
Mira the funny thing is is I feel like I
could just wake up and eat a giant
burger and the only thing the only
reason I don't is because I don't want
to be judged but if it was just me if it
was name-based me and you and Morgan on
an island right and the one thing we
brought was like burger machine that was
the sixth thing it wasn't a yacht it was
just a machine that every time you open
it there was a new burger that would be
cool first of all but second of all I
would open that machine up every morning
you probably would - because it would
have a burger in it and be better than
anything we could find and kill
but that doesn't help us thing and get
into this answer but the only reason I
don't order dinner for breakfast is
because a it's not served often and B I
just you know I feel like I'm gonna be
judged but but I think if you look at
cultural norms across cultures mirror
you'll find that it varies so much that
it has to lead us to conclude that it's
it's it's all just just regional habits
nothing more nothing less
I'm sure if we and I think we can trace
those regional habits to like okay it
might be when the chickens lay their
eggs or when you're expected to do
certain things in different places but
but it up but it's all a construct of
course you could also that's my answer
you could also just google this this
question and you probably get a more
educated answer but it wouldn't be as
fun that wouldn't be fun right the point
is not to no the point is to act like
you know to just have a conjecture ation
about it yeah just have a conversation
don't worry about facts we went through
two of them but I would I would kill for
some some pancakes at this point not too
late it's about dinner time for us I'm
gonna leave here and I may eat something
pancakes huh I'm not hungry because we
had a we had a late lunch I didn't eat
any of it oh you didn't eat any of it
now didn't ya yeah I made I made a
mistake I think you know we ended up
eating eating lunch at like 4:30 and so
I'm gonna get home
and you know if sometimes we we do
takeout sometimes we you know do some
kind of prepared meal and then sometimes
Jesse I'll just make something sometimes
I make something but if she's like
worked on something and she's like she
was kind of excited about me trying it
I'm put into this situation where either
I just don't tell her that I ate at 4:30
and I just eat it and tell her that it's
great oh yeah or I get there I'm like ah
I'm not that hungry you know we had a
really late lunch I need you to help me
with this decision what should I say she
faked it
absolutely
because what's the worst that could
happen what she could listen back to
this you eat a lot of food she could
listen to this for the first time ever
but it probably won't be as much of a
disappointment if she listens to this
and I be and I'll be like Sheba oh when
you came home and you ate that food
you said you enjoyed it but you know I
know that you weren't hungry I think
it's more important that at the time
she felt affirmed well I think the most
important thing is that I like to not
eat my lunch so that I can enjoy
whatever plans we have for dinner as a
family tonight that's much more
important than me eating earlier as long
as my family takes that away then I'm
golden but is that really why you didn't
choose to eat oh absolutely
you didn't choose eat because we already
eat a bunch of crap on the show which is
also the case yeah the stuff that we ate
on the show was so not sustaining so we
eat a lot of crap yes show days my
speaking of which yeah I mean we eat a
lot of non breakfast food on the show
for breakfast that's why I'm like
breakfast of champions I say that a lot
because it's really difficult we we have
to get in a lunch or dinner mindset with
all the stuff we eating the show which
is most all the time shut close closest
to the breakfast meal right so again
we've we've trained ourselves to enjoy
all types of things you can to Mira
thank you for your questions thank you
for coming down the rabbit hole with us
thank you for joining us for another
episode of ear biscuits the rabbit had
two holes today yep awesome
[Music]